Silicon Valley has always had a special
relationship with acid Steve Jobs
experimented with it in the 70s and
today people are micro dosing with it at
startups what fascinates me about
bladder is like what fascinates me about
all good art it changes your mind this
is the Institute of illegal images a
free San Francisco museum full of tiny
LSD icons printed on blotter paper early
brands once is recognizable to those in
the know as emoji are today my name's
Martin McLeod and I've come to this
planet to reduce the amount of suffering
by collecting blobby it all started in
the early 1970s a supper knife 1971 I
took the most powerful substance on
earth and it was a hit of Nicky sands
orange sunshine and I happen to fall out
a window out of my kisser and die in the
middle of it and thanks to the LSD I was
reborn that's why I collect blather a
small thank you for the thing that saved
me of course
curating artwork soap in a Schedule one
drug has also caught the interest of the
Drug Enforcement Agency when they came
in to bust me look first one they came
in and took off the wall which was up
there out in the wall number one this so
happens to be a mandala that went
inspected closely turns out to be the
seal of the FBI so they started with
that one has been moved all the way
through they numbered about 350 of them
while the last trial the DA claimed I
had thirty three thousand sheets of
course I had many many more now you only
need a thousand sheets of a thousand to
make a million hit that's right that's
all it is
here we're running in a perforation
barge off of printing press this is a
good way to turn that seven and a half
inch by seven and a half inch art piece
into 900 little hits or chats as I say
in the political world so then there you
got you know 900 new friends McLeod's
collection has been featured in books
and news articles and magazines
including an early issue of Wired with a
gray Dino on the cover 95 wire drama
article about blotter Arts and they
asked me for many many examples to lay
out this issues brought in the trial
this is with evidence in the court trial
my last trial yeah my co-conspirator
wired so wired
involved up to their necks